I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
Adele in tears at her Vegas residency
yeah absolutely yeah
it all started after a fan attending the
show shared a personal moment with the
singer
just after Adele finished singing When
We Were Young she takes a moment to
explain their interaction
I think that's his wife on his phone
and I don't think she's here and it was
really big with me
around and I just I'm so sorry the
Grammy winner gets emotional over what
seems to be the audience member's loss
I'm so sorry
sorry
it's so beautiful Adele's always making
time to connect with the crowd
[Music]
[Applause]
like this hilarious encounter
or when she paused the show to give a
birthday shout out to a special someone
[Applause]
[Music]
happy birthday
yeah the star took a moment to celebrate
boyfriend Rich Paul
I love it more than life itself and we
wish you Happy Birthday the pair's been
going strong since 2021 when they first
sparked romance rumors while courtside
at an NBA game about autonomy life and
the older I get the more and more I love
myself and I'm enjoying my life
[Music]
foreign